do you think of feminism are you a
feminist okay so tricky one so I
wouldn't say like I identify and label
myself as a feminist but I think I agree
with a lot of their values okay which
ones okay so I think the main value I do
agree with is the fact that they believe
men and women should be treated equally
that's that's the main driver for me
okay I think that women should be below
men okay yeah that's where we did it
because and I'll tell you why I think
it's because they do all of the hardest
jobs in society so when it comes to like
I don't think you should have be equal
if we're going to be equal I say be
equal do 50 of the electric work do
fifty percent of the plumbing do 50 of
all the hardest until women want to do
that it's like we can't be equal if
we're not gonna do do equal